this is a production of Cornell
University all right hi everyone thanks
for coming I mentioned today a little
bit about the scalability of ecological
farming practices in the United States
it's part my PhD research my research
primarily focused or I should say
divided in two different parts
part of it is in-depth interviews with
farmers in New York and California and
the other half is this National Survey
today it's largely going to focus on
that survey so to begin with I want to
show you a photo I took in California
last year and so this is a specialty
crop farm it's tens of thousands of
acres I won't be more specific for the
anonymity of this farmer but they grow
on one side here you can see some
cabbage and other side carrots so we
look a little closer this is about an 80
acre field that they consider a field
and each of these different colors here
is a different cultivar of cabbage and
you some red cabbage here and a few
different cultivars of green and those
are about 15 acres on the other side
you've got carrots the same thing 80
acres 15 acre blocks and so what you
might have noticed snow weeds at all an
incredible uniformity one side of the
road is managed conventionally and one
side is managed organically and so what
this really makes me think about a lot
of scale and so how do practices differ
under each management approach and how
different is a management on a form of
this size compared to entire farms that
are smaller than just one field on a
farm of this scale so I want to take a
step back and look at some of these
changing farm demographics in the US so
we're gonna go through a little bit of
data from the USDA ers and so here what
we're looking at our u.s. farms the
number of farms in 1987 and then 15
years later in 2012 so what you notice
is farms that are relatively small one
to forty nine acres the number of farms
from 1987 has actually increased since
going towards 2012 the number of
mid-sized farms so I'm 50 to 999 acres
dropped by nearly half and the number of
very large farms so over 2000 acres
nearly doubled and so what we see in
terms of total farmland in the US so on
the access here this is just percentage
of total u.s. cropland and so it's about
910 million acres along the bottom we
see again those same dates 1987 going to
2012 and what you're looking at is in
1987 at the top here those farms that
were over 2,000 acres comprised about
15% of that total cropland where as 15
years later they comprised 36% of that
cropland
during that same time period those
mid-sized farms their share of total US
cropland dropped by 21% so we can look
at some of these changing relationships
in all different ways here you've got
the number of farms by the average farm
size if you follow the blue line we can
see that from 2010 to 2017 the number of
farms is decreasing and the average farm
size is increasing and actually if you
look at some of those numbers the number
of farms has decreased by about a
hundred thousand farms since 2010 all
the average farm size is increasing so
as I mentioned the total farm lands
about 910 million acres and if we look
now just at 2016 to 17 that decreased by
about a million acres notably farms in a
sales class of over a million dollars
annually actually operated 1.3 million
acres more than they did the previous
year if we break down these sales
classes into just those who gross less
than half a million to those who grossed
more than half a million what you
actually see is that 41% of the total
farm land is operated by just 8% of
those farms so those farms that are
grossing over half a million dollars so
there's different ways of looking at
this type of consolidation but the
picture is relatively consistent in
terms of farms getting larger and also
occupying more and more of that total
acreage so we know that the industrial a
graffiti is been highly productive but
it's also produced many environmental
socio political cultural and economic
costs here you're looking at algal bloom
in the Gulf of Mexico
from eutrophication and nutrient runoff
so rather than go through a long list of
all sorts of different implications of
industria gonna shift towards an
alternative and so one of those is
agroecology a lot of you might think of
agriculture is just simply that
portmanteau of agronomy and ecology is a
scientific discipline and that's how it
was initially introduced or in the
1920's 1930's but since then it's
evolved and it starting to bring in a
lot of social sciences and rather than
focusing just on the field or plot scale
it's now moved to kind of the food
system level a hury called u also
consists of a series of practices which
is going to be the main focus of this
talk and these are things like diverse
crop rotations cover cropping a new
tillage and border plantings and I
should also note that it's important
that another aspect of every call G is
kind of this social movement and it's
the idea that to increase adoption of
agricultural practices need a social
carrier you need some farmer to Farmer
knowledge sharing and these movements
are closely aligned with food
sovereignty so I think you'll and land
reform or water rights and food justice
which addresses inequality in the food
system on many other many other
challenges and I should just know
briefly that that previous kind of
schematic or model has been critiqued as
kind of parm analyzing on what agora
ecology means and some authors have
suggested that really think of those
three as very interconnected and
inseparable and so just to briefly say
that there's different as these authors
talk about kind of dominant perspectives
or agroecology x' and some of these are
more interdisciplinary and top-down
maybe a little apolitical and they tend
to be focused on the transformation of
agricultural production where some
people might be focused more on kind of
a politically engaged action-oriented
approach that's interested in
transforming natural agri-food system
and certainly we need both of these
approaches as well as all the variants
in between and hopefully there's some
reciprocity and communication among
people with different skill sets so kind
of mentioned a handful of these
different practices but focusing more on
my research and the eight different
practices I'm interested in we can look
at where they operate or what scale they
operate on so for thinking about within
field
compost or manure applications
intercropping so different crop species
in the same space so these could be by
rows strips are mixed and in insectary
plantings and so these are non crop
plants that are used to attract
beneficial insects so it could be
natural enemies or pollinators when we
look at the field scale we have reduced
tillage so that's a reduction in tillage
frequency or intensity crop rotation
which should be fairly self-explanatory
and by crop rotation we're thinking of a
diverse crop rotation which I would
suggest it's kind of a low bar but we're
thinking at least three crops in
rotation I think we have cover cropping
which everyone I think is familiar with
but crops that are not grown for food
theatres fiber fuel and for other
benefits like weed suppression or
nitrogen fixation and then finally at
the perimeter or landscape level we have
border plantings which can be important
habitats for a variety of Wildlife as
well as beneficial insects tend to
include a lot of woody perennials and
then riparian buffers which are similar
but associated of course with waterways
on farms so these are the eight
practices that we're going to talk a
little bit about today these are these
were the focus of my survey so when we
think back again why we might be
interested in this alternative approach
to food production or an agri-food
system we can think about how these
different practices so here are these
eight practices listed across the top
and what type of ecosystem services
though they might deliver so you can see
you the scales that they operate on and
then you can look for example reduced
tillage well it might help increase low
ground biodiversity so I'll so a health
but it's not gonna have a large impact
on pollination services and so we can
look at these different practices from
that kind of ecosystem service lens so
one of our guiding research questions
was how scalable are ecological
practices in the United States a lot of
the research is focused in the global
south and so we wanted to try to look at
this question in the context here we're
interested in how size might have might
affect this is this going to be
different on small farms going to very
large farms there's a different terms of
management's organic conventional
growers and then how does that change
from cropping systems so those who might
grow grains and forages compared to
those who grow specialty crops which
especially crops I mean fruits and
vegetables so just to clarify terms of
scalability I'm a differentiate between
scaling up and scaling out scaling up
would be taking one small farm for
instance kind of a diverse small farm
and could actually be applied on a much
larger scale on larger farm we talk
about scaling out it's that same small
diverse farm or could be medium-sized it
doesn't really matter but it's the idea
of can that be used on farms on a
greater number of farms of similar size
so now shifting to the methodology from
my national survey so if it sends a
little bit of data and I should clarify
that this is preliminary data that
you'll be seeing but walk you through
kind of the process for how we develop
the survey we began with the semi
structured in-depth interviews with
farmers in California in Washington this
helped inform the development of the
questionnaire so we got a better sense
of what farmers you know there are
motivations for using practices the
barriers they were facing as well as a
whole host of other issues that are an
important in terms of understanding
practice use or just use we drafted the
questionnaire I got feedback from our
collaborators we also had a pilot study
on that initial draft and this included
organic and conventional farmers as well
as conventional especially crop growers
revised retested it and then this turned
into an electronic questionnaire through
Qualtrics the survey was long was over
150 questions a lot of mixed question
types multiple choice like or ranked we
had a really diverse distribution
strategy that included things like
social media as well as working with
Extension educators and you see a
database for organic growers and as I
mentioned it was long it took farmers
probably on average an hour to complete
which if anyone's done any survey work
you tend to ask maybe 5 to 15 minutes a
farmer's time so this is a big ask and
it's great to get this kind of rich
detail in a really long survey we had
over 700 completed surveys and then
we've been conducting some uni and
multivariate statistical analyses
so if we're looking at that chill
respond to geography so where are these
farmers from that filled out the survey
we got a nice bump from being associated
with Cornell a good representation in
New York as well as California and a
couple other important fruit and
vegetable growing regions like Oregon
and Michigan as well as Washington
Florida although Florida we'd hope to
get a few more response I should also
mention the focus was probably more in
specialty crop growers then then grains
because they're usually under research
especially in this type of work so very
briefly in terms of who filled this
survey out farm size range from a 1 acre
to 7,000 we definitely had an organic
farmers and conventional farmers fill
this out part of that reflects the fact
that there's a public database of
organic growers of thousands of growers
that I could access an email to and that
doesn't exist for conventional growers I
made this much more challenging as far
as I'm size increases the proportion of
farmers that grow grains increases which
is what you might expect and farming
experience we had certainly some
beginning farmers maybe only be farming
around a year two very experienced
farmers I've been farming for over four
decades and this is just that
distribution account the number of
farmers across these different kind of
groupings of farm size that the USDA
uses so again returning to that research
question how likely is a formula to use
a certain ecological practice how does
Pharma size affect this likelihood how
important management and cropping system
and do these three factors interact so
we use the binomial logistic regression
model we've got your binomial user
disused says 1 or 0
and then we looked at those three
factors as a three-way interaction and
just very briefly this model was based
on literature review and our hypotheses
we had to check for separation if we
found complete or quasi complete
separation we need to simplify the model
and then we also assess
multicollinearity by calculating the
variance inflation factor so these are
important Diagnostics so that we can
feel more confident our interpretations
from these types of models and so what
this ended up but in
happening was that we needed to simplify
the model because we had a few of those
different issues and so we used an
additive model still with those three
main effects but not a multiplicative so
just to clarify this is the response so
whether our former uses or does not use
a practice this uses a zero uses one
farm size was a continuous variable
that's land in production by Hector's
management is three levels
it's a categorical variable organic
conventional and split and cropping
system is also categorical you have your
fruit and vegetables so your specialty
crops grains and forage and mixed
operations if we look at the ANOVA table
from this perhaps a little surprisingly
farm size does not have such a strong
effects as we might have expected
especially given the whole scalability
focus of this research but management of
cropping system certainly does and there
are a few things that we could still
follow up with like I said this is
preliminary and so we know there are
some interactions here with farm size
and management and there's just
different ways we can parameterize this
model so there's a lot of data on here
I'll walk you through this figure
hopefully this makes sense so on the y
axis we've got your predicted
probability of using a practice zero
means you're not using the practice one
means that they used it all these black
dots these are all our actual
observations so for all the figures
following you're only going to see
observations at zero or one because a
farmer either said they did or did not
use a practice and here we're looking at
across farm size along the x axis in
general you can see that as farm size
increases the likelihood that a former
is going to use these practices
decreases but a lot of these slopes did
not have a significant effect if we pull
out one that does we can look at compost
manure so we can see that as farm size
increases here we can see that negative
relationship here so growers are less
likely to use composted manure as they
scale up which should make sense compost
manure is expensive it's time-consuming
labor-intensive to move such a bulky
material over really large acreages
there are exceptions this is taken photo
taken at a farm in California also
visited it's a three hectare compost
facility and they use this compost on
both our conventional and again if we
look at crop rotation use by size we see
that at size increases farmers are more
likely to use crop rotation but this is
a little bit confounded with the fact
that some farmers that are not using a
crop rotation are exclusively growing
woody perennials so these are your and a
lot of these farmers are down here and
these are some specialty crop growers
that are orchardists or those who grow
cane crops if we look now at the use of
these practices by management this is
the same format so zero means they don't
use it one means they do use it and
again these are our actual observations
here this is a lot of data so you can
also compare the means that's even more
data to look at so let's try to pull out
some that maybe are interesting so these
five here have a very similar
relationship if we simplify this a
little further or move those split
operations and just focus on
conventional organic growers we can see
the same trend across all five of those
practices and so we'll go through these
and look how look at some of these
results so for compost or manure use
this is the probability that farmer is
going to use compost manure if their
organic is about a seventy five percent
likelihood for conventional growers
that's forty four and of course we're
going to farmers are prohibited from
using synthetic fertilizers so that
should make sense this is pretty this is
expected there's still a fair number of
organic growers not using compost or
manure so presumably these are relying
on legume cover crops and perhaps of my
materials like Chilean nitrate although
there's a twenty percent rule on organic
egg if we look at intercropping
predicted probability if your organic
farmer of using intercropping at sixty
three percent compared to 22 percent of
commercial farmers convention weed
management with synthetic herbicides you
can imagine is going to be complicated
if you have a bunch of your crop
families and then also though on the
organic side of things we know that a
lot of diverse farms that grow for
farmers are
as the CSA's tend to be organic smaller
acreages and they're almost constrained
by land and why they might be
intercropping a lot of different species
together if we look at in Sector e
plantings 58% for organic farmers 26%
for conventional again some of these are
just there's not a lot of data on some
of these relationships we would expect
some of these things but this project is
actually putting some numbers to what
the literature suggests it and so again
this is maybe what you'd expect
conventional farmers are going to be
less likely to integrate biological
control using these insectary plantings
if they're using synthetic insecticides
there's an obvious conflict there this
is a photo from a farm a 200 hectare
organic farm in California this is a
bunch of Brussels sprouts and what you
see here are intercropped cilantro so
let's that cilantro got a flower and
that's going to attract some surfing
flies so some hover flies which are
really useful for taking care of some
problematic pests in these brassicas on
the same farm this isn't said cabbage
and this is just a different form of
intercropping here he's actually makes
intercrop dill and that's going to
attract a slightly different suite of
beneficial insects again to take care of
some problematic pests in this brassicas
so if we look at cover crop use by
management organic farmers what 76
percent compared to conventional farmers
you might think of the reliance on
cultural practices for organic farmers
you know if they're using legume cover
crops for nitrogen conventional farmers
have arguably a lot easier alternative
and synthetic fertilizers so a lot of
this stuff is more or less what we would
expect which is good it validates our
model and notice that we're moving in
the right direction
order planting so our hedgerows 55% for
organic farmers 36 for conventional
again this might be related to an
evaluation of biological control
hedgerows can also be really important
just like in secretary plantings for
providing some habitat for beneficial
insects if we
look at ecological practices now by
cropping system this story is a little
bit more messy especially when we take
into consideration these mixed
operations so those are growers that
have both grains and field crops as well
as fruits and vegetables on their farms
so for simplicity sake we'll pull out
one where it's a little bit of a clearer
picture and we'll just remove that mixed
mixed operation here again so we can
just see a simpler relationship so
specialty crop growers here oh I didn't
mention this before these are 95%
confidence intervals it's a little late
to mention it now but all the great bars
are especially crop growers 57% chance
that they're going to use in sector
replanting compared to 11 for grains and
forages which might suggest that the
role of biological control is
undervalued by grains and fields crop
growers arguably it might be more
important for specialty crop but there
still is a role for those biological
control agents in grain and field crop
operations so I want to now shift a
little bit to motivations and barriers
when we think about the use and issues
of these practices it's one thing to
model and see who is and is not using
but we also want to understand a little
bit why they may or may not be using
these practices so when a form of
thinking the survey this is just an
example using hedgerows they would get a
question like describe the use of
hedgerows on your farm they have three
options currently use use in the past
but not anymore never use if they
selected currently use they'll be given
a follow-up question which asked which
of the following reasons were most
important in your decision to plant or
maintain hedgerows you can select up to
five of your most important reasons and
so here there's a pretty long list of
about twelve different options that
might be important to them so what we're
looking at here in this table to
simplify things these are just the top
three reasons along the left-hand side
here you've got these different
motivations this is increased yield
management pollination these are kind of
agronomic reasons there's kind of some
environmental reasons increasing or
improving local water quality or
increasing
laughs habitat reducing external inputs
these are kind of related to economics
and these are more ants capable farmland
related motivations again this is that
same order of those eight ecological
practices and these again are your
predicted probabilities these are across
all farm sizes types and management and
so just like before you know something
like this 95% chance we're almost
certain that you know for compost or
manure a farmer is going to say that
they're using that practice because of
soil health reasons so if we want to
look at a few ones that kind of stand
out you can look at soil health so
farmers definitely felt strongly about
that as a motivation for using these
practices six out of the eight practices
so a health is one of those top three
motivations and they're also those
predicted probabilities are pretty high
for a lot of them maybe less so for
riparian buffers and that one's maybe a
little less obvious perhaps they were
thinking about reducing wind erosion but
it's not actually clear why a riparian
buffer to improve soil health pest
management also was a pretty important
motivation for using good practices in
this case intercropping and secretary
planting crop rotation and cover
cropping and if we look at improving
water quality and wildlife habitat these
environmental reasons or motivations
only showed up for border planting and
riparian buffers so your landscape level
ecological practices and you know one
thing that this name you think about was
how different at least what the farmers
I was interviewing and certainly in the
literature how different farmers view
environmental stewardship and the
interaction with farming and so this
certainly has some implications for how
we might try to encourage the adoption
of these practices so oh I should
mention what I was gonna say I remember
interviewing one farmer he said that he
would stop his tractor if he saw a frog
hopping across the rows in front of him
couple weeks later I talked to another
farmer who poured high doses of call for
sulphate and ponds to kill all I'm
phibian some wildlife because it was
seen as a food safety threat so pretty
different pretty different perspectives
on Wow
on the farm so when we're thinking about
barriers to using ecological practices
it's a similar kind of format again
we're just using hedgerows as that model
there's an example in this case they
would say they never used it then
they're gonna be prompted with a new
question these are not exactly the same
as those options for currently using of
course they have to be a little bit
different and not all these even
necessarily make sense in terms of
improving yield and stuff like that it's
just we needed to keep some consistency
across that and also make sure that
farmers aren't just randomly selecting
questions I should also minister with
all of these practices everything was
randomized so the farmers didn't see the
same questions always in the same order
so it wouldn't be like farmers just
selected the top five to move through
this long survey really quickly because
we would see that type of pattern so
these were all randomized to try to
account for that so here's the same kind
of format and here we have the most
important barriers again we're just
looking at the top three in terms of
predicted probabilities that they might
select that reason as an important
barrier for not using a practice and
what you might notice is that these
predicted probabilities are all a lot
smaller those numbers are a lot lower
than with those motivations so this is a
little this is worded a little awkwardly
but essentially there's a greater number
of important barriers preventing farmers
from using these practices and there are
important motivations so in other words
you know it's more universal that
farmers are going to want to use script
practices for things like so health or
improving pest management whereas we're
talking about barriers these are a lot
more diverse and the reasons that
farmers see or these barriers against
using practices are distributed across a
much greater number of different
barriers or reasons that makes sense so
this is going to obviously make it more
challenging to identify important
barriers that farmers assuming they're
interested in adopting a practice need
help overcoming and kind of reinforcing
this is a lot of farmers entered text
options for barriers these aren't very
high predicted probabilities but
to the other ones I made it into top
three these were still showing up is one
of the top three reasons of course there
other reasons aren't all the same but
this just emphasizes that a lot of them
were very specific like it's my soil
type what I can't use this and the
microclimate where I live or all my
neighbors are conventional and it
affects the way I can manage
biodiversity in my farm and they're all
very specific to their farm or or County
and so that yeah this really emphasizes
the fact that this issue of barriers is
going to be a little bit harder to
address than trying to motivate through
common shared values if we look at one
that does show very really commonly it's
that farm size was too large so it
didn't seem feasible to use these
practices that showed up in six out of
the eight but based on our model we saw
that farm size was only a significant
effect for compost or manure as well as
crop rotation use so this suggests that
you know there's some misperceptions
here in terms of what berry actually
exists so experience versus perception
also when we look at the mean farm size
of those farmers that selected that they
did not use these different practices we
know from all those different
observations that we have a lot of
farmers using you know compost or manure
or intercropping and secretary planning
on forms that are much larger than any
of these averages so again there's a
little bit disconnect between perception
and experience and so this is a you know
a really great opportunity perhaps to
shift how we might talk about some of
these practices and Desai's provide
examples connect farmers with other
farmers of similar size so that they can
see that yes you can use in secretary
plantings on a farm that's 500 hectares
it doesn't have to be on a you know a 10
acre farm and if we do look at in
secretary planting so the top three
reasons here these are just pulling out
a couple of somewhat interesting
examples from this from these data
so yes farm size showed up also lack of
information support in secretary
plantings is a fairly complex management
practice there's a lot of details there
to understand so this is good stuff to
communicate we have people interested
from
and we can tease some of these details
out also with our interviews and so this
is something we can definitely address
something like food safety regulations
this is more challenging we there are
private food safety consultants these
are typically for really large scale
farms and they might recommend removing
all non-crop vegetation for food safety
concerns this is not what the Food
Safety Modernization Act or good
agricultural practices policy suggests
some of that stuff's fairly big in terms
of where they see threats to food safety
and this is obviously more applicable to
fruit and vegetable growers but we also
know that especially for some of these
large operations they all have food
safety consultants on staff they're part
of that operation and sometimes they use
much more stringent approaches to
managing that farm and so this is a
little bit more challenging and this
gets the fact that we're trying to
address some of these issues it's not
just you know cover crop seeds too
expensive or I don't have the right
equipment for doing reduced tillage
there's some much larger and sometimes
food system level issues here or
challenges that we need to overcome and
that's part of what we're trying to
address in a survey that's this broad so
one last example here of barriers we're
looking at border plantings here and one
of the more important reasons for not
using it well as farmers said they just
had natural areas nearby so their farms
were surrounded by forests this is
obviously can be very reaching specific
in upstate New York
yeah you can understand why a farmer may
not have hedgerows or shelterbelts
dividing up their farm because they're
surrounded by a bunch of deciduous
forests
whereas in California in the Salinas
Valley where some of those images were
from that's going to be very different
and the importance of a hedgerow in an
area like that is going to be a lot
different than a landscape like upstate
New York so we're turning into that
question how scalable are ecological
practices in the u.s. if we look at farm
size we think about scaling up so
scaling up composted manure based on
some of these four limiting results
that's going to be fairly challenging
we're talking to actually the farmer
from the first image that I showed you
coincidentally
you quoted me that to use compost on his
organic acreage cost $3,000 an acre and
his conventional land for fertilizers
its $45 that is an enormous difference
and yet he's only seen growth in his
organic sales and as organic acreage and
is continually looking to increase
acreage and so that also reflects some
of the economics involved in operations
like this an organic versus conventional
but just there's physical limitations
imagine these farms that are tens of
thousands of acres enormous fields and
trying to move all this material in
terms of management we don't think about
scaling out that's going to be
challenging for practices that conflict
with the use of synthetic insecticides
and herbicides so as we already talked a
little bit about those insectary
plantings that's going to be pretty
tough to integrate on conventional farms
if they're using a lot of different
insects decides throughout the growing
season and one thing I will note from
some of my interviews and this is where
later on it'll be really nice to kind of
bring these together in a mixed methods
approach a lot of the farms in
California were split operations so they
might have some acreage and organic and
some unconventional and what was really
fascinating why we wanted to talk to
some of these farmers that did both was
that they would almost very very
consistently they would say that
insectary plantings on their organic
acreage so they might be planting things
like alyssum or dill or cilantro were
very very effective for instance in
their broccoli or cabbage 14-carat
Brassica pests and then I asked so it's
like well have you ever considered using
that in your conventional acreage like
if it's so effective in your organic
what's stopping you from using it in
York on your conventional land and the
answer is buried but essentially none of
them did that and it's just part of how
they manage it they're just separate
operations and it was just it's kind of
perplexing and I'd like to probe that a
little bit more but there's there's so
there's some cultural things going on as
well in terms of how people think about
agriculture and in production but I just
found that fascinating when I was
talking to these growers
terms of cropping system increasing the
use of practices such as intercropping
on grain farms so here in new york a lot
of our Ganic farmers you have some
leaders in the organic area and they do
things like frost seeding red clover
into a small grain and that's gonna
provide some nitrogen for the quarter
crop that follows you know we need to
require we need to continue outreach and
a lot of there's some people in this
room including my adviser that does this
type of work and certainly more
formative farmer knowledge sharing
co-creation of knowledge is can be
really important for scaling out some of
these practices that we know work and we
have a lot of support for that terms of
next steps going to assess the economic
socio-political aspects of the survey by
analyzing some of the data that I did
not show you today so really we just
touched upon the small slice of that 150
questions survey there are whole
sections on things like marketing
economics labor and mechanization
wildlife conservation and biodiversity
on the farm food safety as well as other
regulations advice and information
sources so who do these farmers turn to
on they have challenges or who they look
for for information on new practices and
then also climate change and then
finally as I mentioned a few minutes ago
we really want to take a mixed-methods
approach to kind of improve our
understanding and so that's where the
resolution or the level of detail in
these semi-structured in-depth
interviews are going to really help
inform and support some of the stuff
that we're finding on this national
survey so even though this quest or the
survey is very broad we can't get to the
level of detail that I can get to
sitting down with a farmer for three
hours and allowing them to you know go
into great detail on why they may or may
not use certain practices or how
difficult it is for them to get enough
labor on their farm and all these other
issues that they might be grappling with
so terms of acknowledgments definitely
want to acknowledge my entire project
team here at Cornell as well as Sasha
Jeanette Rebecca Benna
heart that the nature conservancy as
Matt mentioned this is a project that's
a collaboration between Matt Ryan ritual
bezler Corrales and power Thomas Berkman
Miguel Gomez here at Cornell with the
Nature Conservancy we have collaborators
at UC Berkeley definitely want to thank
all the former interviewees that helped
inform the development of this survey
pilot study participants and the survey
respondents of course Steven Perry and
Erica mudra at CSC you Christine Jess in
Hana helped out a lot with all of our
interviews and the Ryan Buzz record
drink water and eat wasa labs provide a
lot of release or feedback when I gave
previous iterations of this presentation
and Linda Leslie and Todd for a lot of
administrative stuff that is always very
challenging and I sincerely appreciate
all their help and certainly funders
Atkinson Center and the Natural Sciences
and Engineering Research Council Canada
and so I think we have a little bit time
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that's a great question it's
something I've considered yeah there is
some data certainly with the USDA with
Nass other surveys where they do ask
things are like crop rotation or reduced
tillage or conservation tillage and
cover cropping and that would be really
interesting to try to look at that and
see how that compares with my data to
see how that biased or skewed my data is
certainly as I mentioned we know we have
more organic for most conventional it
skews toward smaller scale farms this
also reflects some of the challenges
with some of those more complicated
models that we were working with I gave
interviews to like the corn and soybean
die
and I tried really hard to get
conventional growers to fill the survey
out I did my best to keep the language
very neutral when we were looking for
farmers but a big challenge is that
there's the USDA integrity database
that's that's all organic farmers in the
US it's thousands and thousands of
farmers that I could send a bulk email
to and ask them to take this survey and
that doesn't exist for conventional
growers and that made this really
challenging to try to get more
conventional growers yeah so there's I
think that's a point well taken it's
something I'm interested in looking into
and seeing how we can better understand
our data by looking at existing what
they do lists so I did my Master's
research as you know traditional and
found that a lot of barriers related to
group under an umbrella plan tenure
issues tended to dissuade or be
challenging for farmers to adopt certain
so for example my landowner things that
look sloppy and might not have to be
next year or it's not worth the
investment when I have you know one year
then I wonder did that come out at all
areas not coming out in your interview
it's a very different there very
different social ecological yeah so the
question was whether or not land tenure
and the difference between farmers that
may rent land compared to own it does
that influence their practice use or
disuse and certainly that's something we
ask both in the survey and in the
interviews
and at least based on the interviews
conduct so far a lot of the farmers seem
to suggest that aside from some of those
kind of landscape level practices like
hedge rows or riparian buffers they
weren't like using cover crops on own
land and not using on a rented
we weren't seeing that and there
certainly is literature about
exactly what you're talking about and
that would make sense in terms of maybe
not wanting to use as many resources on
land that you only have you know the
land is tenable you maybe only have it
for a few years but that wasn't
necessarily what we were seeing one
thing that I'll say about the survey is
that's one of seeing a seemingly
infinite way I could subset this data we
could look at some of these responses in
terms of I did total acreage here but we
could look at those on rented land
versus owned land so I do have that data
this was just all that land together as
a total and so that's where we need to
make sure I'm not gonna be my PhD
forever but there's a lot of different
interesting things to look at and that's
certainly something that's of interest
land tenure is really important that did
come up especially for young and
beginning farmers that is a major major
challenge and something that took for
further you alluded to this about the
Lindt you didn't say anything of the
landscape you talked about are we
surrounded by forests or we have a I
think would be interesting you know
where these are right you have a
location of all these so you can relate
them to the landscape metrics farms in
the survey yep no oh well I
okay well yes I know I know what County
they're in we don't ask what were you I
was thinking if you knew the spot of
each farm actually and then you can do
something like brag stats or something
to over a characterize the landscape and
see if that landscape characterization
is somehow related yeah and that would
be really interesting yeah landscape
level effects for all this or really key
and that came up a lot in the interviews
both ways farmers that were organic
saying they're surrounded by credential
farms and that that was having a major
impact in terms of you know especially
if they different parcels and some were
surrounded by other organic farms or
forests compared to those that were only
surrounded by a bunch of conventional
farms especially really simple
conventional large-scale farms they
noted how different it was in terms of
that biological control and vice versa
other commercial farmers said well
there's poorly managed organic farms all
around me I have tons of pest problems
but you will you tissues and stuff but
you wouldn't even know the location I
would need to know the location I've
county level data that's as
that's his fine love degree why we
needed to in terms of IRB and some of
these things asking farmers for their
specific address is generally frowned
upon perhaps it's not typically that we
do in terms of keeping this anonymous I
should say you know frowned upon but
just in terms of the approach so did we
ask like how long have they been using
cover crops and if that's changed since
they've been farming yeah and that level
of so the question was whether or not we
have some data on practice use over time
we have some of that from our interviews
so certainly we can ask farmers how long
they've been using these practices and
what sometimes really inform it is when
they stop using a practice so the
reasons why they felt that it was it was
not very effective those can be pretty
insightful and the survey that would be
hard to get at that's similar to it
makes me think of you know I wish we
knew on what percentage of their land
they actually use these practices some
farmers might have a few insectary
strips well if they have a few thousand
acres and they've got a couple strips
that's different than someone using on
all their fields across all their
acreage and that's the kind of level of
detail we couldn't get to in this so in
terms of overtime only in the interviews
yeah and I haven't I haven't coated all
the all the transcripts yet and and
teased Oh
[Music]
actually it's the larger-scale grade and
it's not agent lee they don't really
want to have vision or they're not an
operation so they just they don't need
to look into that as much right that's a
great question so the question was in
terms of that relationship of decreasing
compost or manure use as farm size
increases do we really know that it's
because it's hard to move that around an
expensive time consuming or could it be
because there are grain or field crop I
mean I use that or they don't have been
operational by or they may not be your
city where they can get green waste
which a lot of farmers sometimes use for
their as one of their compost sources
that is definitely something that was
well so in terms of the survey they
could have selected options like we
don't have access to it so we can partly
address that and again this is where
they think these interviews are really
going to be invaluable
farmers certainly can express those more
nuanced responses to a question like
this compared to a survey that yeah for
instance that relationship was across
all cropping systems and management if
you're talking about that regression
curve that's slope so that's where when
we look at some of these interactions if
we reaper amortize these models and look
at some different analyses we may be
able to tease that out a little bit
better yeah and just to clarify so some
of those you know when I when I put a
little interpretation of that of that
figure these are going to change as we
start to look more deeply at some of the
data these are some of these are just
initial interpretations of it based on
literature based on these interviews but
we really need to do a more thorough
review of our qualitative data
location are you looking at yeah so I
don't have it as an extra slide I did
use so there's the I'm gonna forget the
names now there's the USDA has regions
well so there's the farm resource
regions is the most recent iteration of
their ways of categorizing different
areas you're not any had so you know and
there's like a fruitful rim and these
interesting names for these different
areas so I did pull data from from some
of that was geological database
what's so database got all these raster
she's got all that stuff county level
and I mapped it out all our respondents
to those areas tried that in the model
and so yeah we did consider looking at
region and again we have some issues
well because that's those types of maps
are associated with the types of
cropping systems then of course you have
an issue with cropping system being in
the model and so that's what I mean by
there's a couple different ways here
where we can look at trying to specify
this model but we also want to be
careful that certainly not like pee
hacking and just searching for most
significant effects we want to make sure
our model selection is informed by
hypotheses but yes region is something
we're interested in maybe that makes
sense as a random effect maybe maybe not
have cropping system in the model and
have region instead so that's where
future work is going to go but that's a
great question I think region is
important for a lot of these questions
Petros and hedgerows and riparian
buffers yep
yeah that's a great question yeah in
terms of how those responses might
change depending on region but even more
specifically if there's been major
efforts around yeah like the Chesapeake
protecting Chesapeake Bay that is some
of the I know Thomas Bjorkman one of our
team members there's a lot of extension
work and I know he's interested in a
whole series of questions that we might
be able to address with this data set
that our extension educators are
interested in and so something like that
being able to subset the data look at
farmers just around the Chesapeake Bay
or might be affected by some of those
policies or outreach efforts and how
those specific responses what those
specific responses are that is
definitely something we can do this is
all just Dana subsetting and and looking
at specific questions that's what's kind
of exciting about today so I like this
is we can definitely address something
that I don't have the answer off the top
of my head I haven't looked at that
exact question but that is something we
can do given the county level data of
our survey responses yes yeah that's a
great question I've I would love to have
a website that was had some of these
summary statistics you can use shiny
apps through for our users you can have
some interactive stuff you could put in
your region it would change the
distribution of the data on these spots
there's all sorts of things like that
I'd love to do and have this publicly
available I think at some point whether
the website comes to fruition or not I
think making some of this accessible to
others is going to be really important
because as you point out I probably
can't address everything that you know
the benefits that we might have from a
dataset like this and this is where we
have some groups at UC Berkeley as well
as Washington State University that are
interested in some of this they have
separate projects you know in California
might be
focus on strawberry growers up in
Washington it's looking at birds and
pathogens in terms of food safety and
this is where we can collaborate share
some data and they can make use of some
of this this larger scale you know
larger scale information for some of
their more specific questions and this
is perhaps a way to get some more to
have a little bit greater impact with
the days that we have and not have it
all end up on my shoulders yeah so
collaboration that's definitely this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at Cornell edu